Now I'm going to read you some things
from Friedman who wrote the
disappearance of God.
He was trying to look at the underlying
structure of the stories.
Now,
Friedman noted that the books in the Old
Testament were written by a lot of
different people at very different times
and then they were sequenced by other
people for reasons that we don't exactly
understand,
but there's still an underlying
narrative.
There's multiple underlying narrative
unity's despite the fact of that rather
arbitrary sequencing,
and that's a strange thing.
You know,
I guess you could say if you had a
collection of ancient books and you were
trying to put them together,
you try to put them together in some way
that made sense.
Right,
and it wouldn't make sense unless you
stumbled across some kind of underlying
narrative that allowed you to order
them,
and so it's not entirely surprising that
that they're ordered in a manner that's
comprehensible.
But Friedman's comments on the
underlying narrative structure,
part of it was,
well,
we'll go through this.
The books of the Old Testament were
composed by a great many authors
according to both traditional religious
views and modern critical scholarship,
the phenomenon of the diminishing
apparent presence of God across so many
stories through so many books by so many
authors spread over so many centuries is
consistent enough to be striking,
impressive and ultimately mysterious,
but the hiding of the divine phase is
only half the story.
There's another development also
extending across the course of the
entire narrative of the Hebrew Bible,
which we must see before we can
appreciate the full force of this
phenomena and before we can pose the
solution to the mystery of this,
of how this happened.
Gradually from genesis to Ezra and see
that there is a transition from divine
to human responsibility for life on
earth.
The story begins in genesis with God in
complete control of the creation,
but by the end,
humans have arrived at a stage at which
in all apparent ways,
they have responsibility for the fate of
the world.
The first two human beings,
Adam and eve,
take little responsibility themselves.
They do not design or build anything
when they're embarrassed over their
nudity.
They do not make clothes.
They cover themselves with leaves.
It's God who makes their first clothing
for them.
No.
I'm by no means a fully developed
personality.
No,
it is not an every man either.
Broadly speaking,
he reflects a step beyond Adam and eve
and human character and responsibility.
Abraham,
beyond that counts of divine commands
that Abraham does carry out.
The narrative also includes a variety of
stories in which Abraham acts on his own
initiative.
He divides land with his nephew lot.
He battles kings.
He takes concubines.
He argued with his wife Sarah.
On two occasions,
he tells kings that Sarah,
his sister,
out of fear,
that they will kill him to get his wife,
and he arranges his son's marriage.
In the place of the single story of
Noah's drunkenness,
there are,
in the case of Abraham,
the stories of man's life,
the Abraham section that's developed the
personality and of a man of man to a new
degree in biblical narrative,
while picturing in him a new degree of
responsibility.
It is not just that Abraham has kindler
kinder,
gentler,
more intrepid,
more ethical,
or a better debater than his ancestor
noah.
Rather both the Noah and Abraham stories
or pieces of a development of an
increasingly stronger stance of humans
relative to the day before the story is
over.
Humans will become a great deal,
stronger and bolder than Abraham.
I don't know what that means,
you know?
See,
it isn't.
It is certainly the case that the
individual exists in the modern world,
the differentiated self aware,
self conscious individual,
and it's certainly the case that that
wasn't the case at some point in the
past and so it's the case that there's
been a development,
I don't know if you could call it a
progression,
but a development of the autonomous
individual over some span of historical
time.
Now we don't know how long that's been,
but my suspicions are,
it hasn't been that long.
I mean,
I read once about a Neolithic ceremony
that involve the particular placement of
a bear skull in a cave,
and then I read that and they had found
these placements in caves that were at
least 25,000
years old and then I read that they
found caves in Japan among the Ainu who
were the indigenous inhabitants of
Japanese territory and rather archaic
people who had the same ceremony with
the bear and that put the skull in the
same orientation and place in caves and
that that tradition remained unbroken
for about 25,000
years.
And you think,
well,
is it possible for an oral or ritual
tradition to remain on broken for spans
of tens of thousands of years?
And the answer to that is not only is it
possible,
it's actually the norm because like
one chimpanzee is like the next
chimpanzee,
right?
In the progression,
in the biological progression.
If you took a chimpanzee troop now and
you went back 25,000
years and you looked at a chimpanzee
troop,
it'd be the same thing.
There's no historical progression.
That's how you can tell the chimps
really don't have culture because if
they could even create one,
1000th of a percent of culture,
transmissible culture progeneration,
it wouldn't take more than about a
million years before they'd have a whole
civilization and they don't.
They're the same as they were and so the
continuity,
the stability and unchanging nature of
his species,
essentially speaking is the rule that
the variant is us.
It's like what the hell happened after
the last ice age?
Fifteen thousand years ago,
we went from tribal uniform stable to
whatever the hell we are now.
It's this transition from
generic too.
It's something like that and I can't
help but think that that's reflected in
this text and it has something to do
with this transition of consciousness
from,
from what?
From possession by the generic divine to
dominance by this specific individual.
It's something like that.
Is that a neurological transformation?
Is that what this is a record of been?
We don't know.
One of the things you said about God
because human relationship with God as
an object of belief is very complex.
He in his technical writing,
he always talks about the image of God.
He never talks about God.
He talks about the image of God.
He said that the image of God dwells
within us,
not the same thing as God dwelling
within.
Right?
Because we could mean all of these
capacities that we have for transcendent
consciousness could be a byproduct of
biological evolution that could have no
reflection.
They can have no relationship whatsoever
to an actual transcendent reality.
There's no way of telling the
transcendent reality seems to manifest
itself as an element of experience,
but that doesn't mean that it has in
reality outside of this objective,
even if it's even if it exists as it
clearly does,
but
Friedman suggests that what's happening
in the biblical narrative is the
sequential emergence of the individual
as a redemptive force and that the old
testament documents that implicitly,
unconsciously as a consequence of
descriptive fantasy and that that's
what's going on in the book and that so
the Cosmos is under the control of
generic daddy to begin with.
Something like that.
And then that controls shifts to
localized,
identifiable increasingly personal and
detailed individuals.
And you see that in Noah and then you
see the neighborhood and then you see it
in Moses,
and then there's this working out of
what it would mean to be a fully
developed individual.
And that's what these stories,
they're there,
they're like prototypes there.
There are attempts to to to bring about
the proper motive being right and so
Abraham is a is a manifestation of that
because he enters into a covenant with
God.
He's selected by God or interesting to a
partnership with God.
It's not exactly obvious.
God provides him with forward motion and
intuition and leads them towards a
successful mode of being.
And it's complex,
successful motive being.
Because Abraham is a very complex life.
There's plenty of ups and downs,
right?
It's,
it's not unbroken
security of being towards the divine
hand.
Abraham lies and cheats and deceives and
does all sorts of things that that a
real person would do.
And and Moses for example,
killed.
And so these people that the biblical
people are very genuine individuals,
but they're given with all their faults,
right,
with all their sins,
with all their deceit,
they're still put forth as potential
modes of proper models of potential
proper being in the world.
And the entire Corpus of the Bible seems
to be nothing but an attempt to keep
throwing up variance of the personality.
Trying to experiment to find out what
personality works in the world.